alors je suis un tournage pas de tout
repos parce que le jacques bral du site
à faire 50 prise il les veut oui oui
c'est pas lui qui chantait ne me quitte
pas oui c'est ça oui
si la note pourtant one basé le fonds de
2,5
oui oui non d'un seul coup ça un diamant
qu'aux élus tellement heureux que comme
les enfants qui pensent qu'à jouer et ça
fait deux ans qu'il n'a pas tourné alors
si leur profil c'est vrai qu'il ya deux
caméras servent un prix aux abandons
cela vous a cherché au montage le mec
que celui qui monte il serait même si
ses bières commence le mec il en veut
donc y avait une scène la scène du parc
met là où c'était à 20h à 2h du matin
des tirs à la corde pour faire que des
allers-retours dans la rue vous aviez
dire je m'en vais oui et donc je suis
rentré chez moi
voilà je sais c'était le texte donc vous
êtes père quand je suis parti n'en
pouvais plus je sais pas ça c'est qu'en
plus malins jeu et chanteurs aussi et
quand même donc oui c'est ça c'est
comment on vous a proposé le film en
fait vous étiez je suis en tournée à
vous êtes ce serait en train de faire là
la scène le soir et le lendemain vous
avez écrit des chansons là pour votre
nouvel album un peu non ça
ça sent bon sain mais les chansons ça
sent bon c'est non enfin bon père un bon
titre
mais non ça ce sont non non comment ça
vous remontez ce teaser de karaoui mars
2007 je rassure tout le monde à faire
est en tournée à partir du 21 mars 2000
toujours avec papadiamandis entre autres
il ya aussi mon camarade dans un jeune
parce qu'il faut aider les jeunes il ya
un mon ami henri salvador
les chansons et salaires on a travaillé
sur deux titres c'est vraiment sympa
c'est bien très bien si c'est qu'elle
est il à eddy 103
c'est jacques 64 mais à bientôt soixante
places et arrive à pourquoi faire une
interwiew when i'm sixty fort